[Music]
let's check out his if uh ha ha hate
horses
no i don't hate rape goats you hate
ghosts
i don't you hate [ __ ] i've loved
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
he's gay
so dumb this is real it's gotta be real
i love cox i like hugs too
thank you
i'm talking about right more wwe stuff
from schneider all right he's a fan
apparently oh oh i'm sorry i seen this
what is
[Applause]
big this damn sorry about it this is
cringe i don't know this is not your
life you crunch side bail minus one side
points
[Music]
you know science love this when there's
random fart noises in there i mean i
like it too i'm not gonna lie
you know funny a funny one i saw
recently jim related this one
random guy thinking he's the biggest in
the gym
mean hoodie what you new
i mean two hoodies watching both of them
i'm in three years watching all of them
how dare someone think they're stronger
than me
idiot fool
i was just thinking there's no way they
can find a bigger drinking bottle but i
guess they can me and no hoodie covering
up most of my muscles that is ginormous
freaking gpu
before we continue quick word from
sponsor what are you doing summer is
here hydrate yourself with g fuel but i
hydrate my drinking water [ __ ]
drink cheap fuel caffeine free version
re-energize rehydrate use of flavor
delicious
shiny splash also taste good will not
kiss you though
punch if there's a flavor you like g
fuel has it as you guys know i love g
fuel
i drink it because it's delicious
it's a great way to hydrate it's not
like other energy drinks that makes you
feel like afterwards just lifts you up
nice little boost i love it it's no
secret check it out and right now most
importantly they have a bogo sale which
is honestly bogus how much money you're
saving by taking advantage just use the
link in the description to get access to
this you don't need to use a code buy
one
get one try it out for everyone that's
saying maybe you don't want to drink
caffeine this is a great alternative and
if you also just want to have a great
flavor drink to rehydrate
it doesn't get better than this so check
it out link is the description thank you
g fuel i love them i kissed it now damn
it
[Music]
oh this is disappointing yes
just wanted to hear the sound effect
come on let's have out here trying to
get me canceled
oh yeah
oh no i'm so sad in the end ah god some
old lady hit me with a car and killed my
dog i don't understand why you would
make a tick puck out of that i
don't get it i mean i understand why you
did it but it just makes it so weird it
makes me feel like a cynical old man for
looking at this and be like you're just
doing this you're literally making a
tech talk out of your dead dog like
that's weird dude i'm gonna say it i'm
going to predict it
tick tock is cringe now but it will be
even more cringe in the future we'll all
just go like what the [ __ ] we all watch
that's what i hope at least i hope there
will be a turning around i'm like ah
hey we all watched that oh watch people
making [ __ ] sounds about and dancing
in front of camera
that was weird that was some friends
[ __ ] bro went back to default settings
when
you're vegan
[Music]
oh my god you're atheist
i'm like
i'm lost by the way i know okay
sometimes i feel like laughing uh you
don't look mexican though like a burrito
i like a taco to look mexican like what
do mexicans look like
[Applause]
we found one the one mexican but i want
it now
yeah that seems about right sony green
lights more bicycles for paramount and
disney plus streaming services early
2024 you think
all right well that meme died so fast
holy [ __ ]
i don't think two years is going to do
it any good musically memorable stuff
i know when your birthday is
june 28th
[Music]
they must have put that in on purpose or
is it a random date every time no they
wouldn't record that many lines yeah
that's on purpose then that's still
funny though i didn't laugh though so
that retracts all my life i'm on zero
nice side yeah you hungry because the
jail won't feed you
i'm being super nice right now
before we get down to jail are you
hungry
don't try to hold me and be like psych
they don't answer the question yes i'm
hungry and have a cup of shut the [ __ ]
up
why would you do that a big surprise
said that okay fine just don't say psych
or anything
technically didn't say psyche
that's what this one hits too close to
home
but with anime music videos back in 2010
dark ages
why does it feel like elevated humor is
just digressing oh i knew the word it's
evolution but backwards i did the meme
it's a word for it
bro i think you look good shaved head
you sure bro yeah man trust me
was there an issue yeah you guys have
id's on you no why okay uh cause they
want you trespass they want us trespass
yes sir but i was just illegally filming
you were illegally filming yeah you're
legally filming yeah like the cinema you
illegally fill me i-l-l-e-g
illegally x
you can't do it i just admitted that you
can't do it well if i get permission
from boss who's boss david who's david
spencer's spencer that's my boss i work
for boss yeah i work for one two three
movies
that i do not know i'm not from here
where do you live everywhere so you're
homeless yeah
okay you know your height and weight
that's kind of personal how is that
personal i kind of get offended by that
okay and he's like five how does he not
get that he's trolling god damn how does
he uh man five eleven we're gonna add a
little inch girls like tall kings that's
fair i guess so there was some
journalism
no we were trying to just illegally film
but they wasn't allowing it i don't
think you understand your term that
you're you said that you're trying to
illegally film yeah it's like the 500th
time he says it illegally you're trying
illegally you just say legally
good job bro 230 days not pissing the
bed that's respectable bro join the no
pissing in bed army nation and subscribe
to this channel right now what i'm not
worth a click why you piss your bed
yes you can like this video and
subscribe huh oh yeah
how come you've got rice look at this
how come you've got
a good night
uk so much
uh mayor bowser and chancellor fairby
you know thank you for joining us as
well
[Music]
and for families across the country
why do you just leave though i
understand it's edited but still my man
just wanted to go huh
there's our elevated sense of humor
again that i i have not reached simon
why am i blurry how long have i been
blurry
god damn how i exposed this camera uh so
i've artificially unblurred me before if
i was blurry thank you and you know what
now you're gonna pay baby
where's the lie
i wish this was way around it can you
just get like a fake credit card number
or something well these work if you sign
up to like netflix doctors be like sorry
you have dimension
i don't remember ask
aldency how many hundred years
[Laughter]
here we go again my baby brother was
eaten by a lion my own trip to africa
last year this is a parody that can't be
true
crying out of that you're not crying a
year later in front of camera what the
[ __ ] is this
i am so confused by tick tock god damn
there are 2 000 pokemon players here in
central park in the center of that
circle playing pokemon i am going to
play a prank and yell the name of a rare
pokemon that is not here let's see what
happens was this during pokemon go oh
yeah it was dragonite
dragonite
damn i just forgot pokemon go was a
thing god damn everyone lost their
goddamn minds detroit you think you
could turn your camera on now we're
going to take a test
can i turn my camera on right now
well would you please turn your camera
on right now so that we could take the
test all together
i don't think i feel like it
uh is there a particular reason you'd
like to share with us about why you
don't want to turn your camera on at
this time
is there a particular reason why you
want to know
[Music]
yeah i'd like to get through this class
today bro just tell him to do it
what you gonna do if we don't get
through this class
well i suppose
nothing
well then that's what i thought excuse
me
this is not turn your camera on please
this is another cases back in my day but
back in my day all right you were
terrified of your teacher isaac newton
died a virgin
that means i have one up on history's
greatest scientific gene then tesla as
well
because i'm not dead
yeah if he's so smart why is he dead huh
all right that was it for you
if you don't piss the bed smash like
subscribe and i see you guys next video
bye
bye
bye